so you're browsing the App Store on your
iPhone and you come across a game titled
Minecraft Pocket Edition to the
description sounds good and you'd love a
sequel to Mojang's classic game but
don't hit that download button it's a
total scam the fraudulent game actually
reached number four on Apple's top
grossing charts so plenty of people have
been fooled our friends at Eurogamer
investigated the game and were met with
quite a surprise
they said Minecraft Pocket Edition 2 is
a terrible top-down swipe game in which
zombies attacks scorpion from Mortal
Kombat I bought it and spent a few
minutes playing it before it crashed my
iPhone if it wasn't already obvious
don't buy it
Mojang is currently working to get the
$7 ripoff removed from the store the
developer has talked about making a
sequel but this definitely isn't what
they had in mind in the meantime you can
try out minecraft story mode or give the
original game ago on pretty much any
platform Under the Sun and if Mojang
ever does reveal a sequel will have all
the blocky details at GameSpot
[Music]